[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
pour ici l'europe dans une union
européenne particulièrement perturbée
par les négociations sur le breakbeat et
la seconde vague de qu'ovide la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne et choix en ces temps
difficiles à l'allemagne et nous
recevons aujourd'hui une allemande
katharina parler bonjour vous êtes
membre du parti social démocrate
d'allemagne au pouvoir en coalition avec
la cdu ou d'angela merkel
vous étiez même ministre de la justice
du précédent gouvernement à la tête de
la liste du spd aux élections
européennes dernière vous êtes
aujourd'hui vice-présidente du parlement
européen
alors je me pose une petite question
quand même sur un fait marquant pour les
français la la mort le décès de l'ancien
président valéry giscard d'estaing pair
avec helmut schmidt le chancelier
social-démocrate pourtant du système
monétaire européen du parlement européen
élu au suffrage universel d'une
constitution rejetée par les français
par référendum
et qu'est ce que vous retenez du
personnage bonjour à vous oui je suis
très triste aussi à cause de son j'ai eu
l'honneur de de les rencontrer moi même
quand j'étais jeune élu au bundestag
dans mon première année je crois et
c'était c'était quand même quelque chose
d'autre et une rencontre très très
impressionnant il était un homme très
impressionnant et surtout quand vous
disais l'amitié avec avec les modes
schmitz deux personnages que grandir est
assez différente mais qui s'entendaient
tellement bien qu'ils étaient vraiment
des amis des vrais amis et cette
confiance entre les deux a facilité
beaucoup de choses pour pour la manip au
pool l'amitié franco allemands mais
aussi pour l'europe
alors on revient à votre hémicycle du
parlement européen avec un mini scandale
le chef de file du fidesz le parti ultra
conservateur hongrois vient de
démissionner de ce parlement alors qu'il
a été arrêté par la police lors d'une
orgie à bruxelles avec 25 hommes nus qui
brisait d'ailleurs la règle du
confinement
vous êtes tenu à l'exemplarité qu'est ce
que vous pensez de cette affaire bon
c'est ça a quelque chose de comique
presque mais c'est très sérieux bien sûr
parce que c'est par sept partis
politiques
elle fait une politique discriminatoire
contre les médias et comme un outil très
très très sévères très très agressif
mais il ya la théorie que des gens qui
sont très très agressive vers les
homosexuels en peut-être une partie on
sait que cela est très forte dans soi
même évidemment c'est le cas pour cet
homme là et ça révèle les précis de sept
partis politiques en croit la fidl
soucier il se gère comme des cons des
patriotes et en même temps c'est une
partie extrêmement corrects victorin et
les politiciens probablement le plus
corrompu en europe très corrompu est-ce
que ça affaiblit pour autant le fides à
bruxelles puisque ce parti fait toujours
partie du parti populaire européen le
grand parti de droite
et pourtant il a traité son président
l'allemand de manfred weber de membres
de la gestapo puis aussi le la populaire
de cette partie de ce parti devient de
plus en plus agressif sur tous contre
les politiciens non parce que il est
comme les polonais aussi le pis le parti
politique
royalement
hollande droit exactement et avec le
narratif nazi parce que il ils veulent
camoufler ce qu'ils font dans leur
propre pays surtout de tous la
corruption alors justement au prochain
sommet au mais paie un des 10 et 11
décembre les discussions vont s'annonce
tendu alors que budapest associé à
varsovie a mis son veto au budget de
l'union européenne au plan de relance
qui est adossé à ce budget pour dénoncer
un nouveau mécanisme qui permettrait de
priver de ces fonds les pays qui ne
respecteraient pas l'état de droit est
ce qu'on va réussir à trouver un terrain
d'entente avec eux bah j'espère bien
parce qu'il faut une solution tout le
monde attend l'argent donc
donc il faut il faut un succès là mais
il joue surtout parce que cette carte
parce que ils ont peur ils savent très
bien qu'ils qu'il qui ne sont pas en
conformité le droit depuis longtemps
depuis dix ans en hongrois en hongrie
depuis cinq ans à pologne il
gray ray désigner leur pays comme des
démocraties libérales comme homme et
comme ils disent
et maintenant il commence aussi essayer
de demeurer redéfinir aussi les valeurs
européennes pas seulement leurs propres
valeurs mais aussi les valeurs
européennes et c'est tellement dangereux
il faut vraiment faire attention là
parce que si m si maintenant on en
étonnerait spa ferme les autres 25 pays
membres
on va changer leur l'union européenne ça
va passer
même union qu'avant alors justement
parlons d'une question qui préoccupe
beaucoup c'est parti la crise migratoire
la crise sanitaire menace-t-elle les
succès de l'intégration en allemagne
dans votre pays dans des centres de
demandeurs d'asile des milliers de
personnes sont actuellement plus ou
moins coupés du monde dans l'incapacité
de s'intégrer à cause des restrictions
sanitaires du confinement
même chose pour ceux qui ont réussi à
refaire leur vie pourtant en allemagne
un reportage signé and my et
interdiction d'entrer ou de sortir ce
centre d'accueil pour demandeurs d'asile
à berlin a été placé en quarantaine
pendant une semaine
hassan a été testés négatifs au co vie
de 19 mais il passe le plus clair de son
temps dans sa chambre un nouveau coup
dur pour une population déjà
particulièrement touché par les
restrictions
environ vingt mille demandeurs d'asile
vivent dans des centres d'hébergement à
berlin pour les tenir informés l'office
régional pour les réfugiés a lancé un
podcast en 14 langues
mais la seconde vague de la pandémie ne
les épargne pas et pour ceux qui ont
déjà trouvé leur place au sein de la
société allemande la situation est
également précaire
sa mère a dû fermer son restaurant il a
réussi à maintenir 50 % de son activité
grâce à un service de livraison
en allemagne la crise sanitaire freine
aussi l'intégration le taux de chômage
parmi les réfugiés les demandeurs
d'asile a augmenté de 23 % lors de la
première vague de la pandémie
alors madame barlet après avoir été mis
en cause notamment par l'extrême droite
la politique migratoire depuis la grande
crise de 2015 dengue et la mer calme
maintenant est un peu mise en échec
quand même par par le cos vide justement
par l'aco vide
oui pour eux c'est vraiment c'est très
grave parce que ils ne peuvent pas
continuer à s'intégrer comme comme vous
avez dit dans la mission là et aussi
dans le secteur économique toujours les
migrants sont un peu plus leur la
situation est un peu plus délicat parce
que parce que souvent ils sont les
premiers à être au chômage quand il ya
des difficultés mais il ya beaucoup de
dead pour les entreprises surtout pour
les pour les petits riens entreprises en
allemagne et donc oui ils sont ils sont
affectés beaucoup mais ils sont affectés
comme comme tout le monde je dirais vous
êtes ancien ministre de la justice avec
une réforme par exemple très importante
du pacte migratoire européen qui
n'arrivent pas toujours à recueillir
l'unanimité des vingt-sept toujours
blocage 1 du côté de l'est qui plaide
d'ailleurs pour un retour de
d'immigrants illégaux plus rapide et
plus efficace avec des accords de
réadmission dans les pays
dans les pays tiers est-ce que ça aussi
on arrivera à progresser en 2020 bon la
politique migratoire c'est vraiment
lente de l'union européenne je dirais
parce que si c'était seulement sur le
sujet de faire entrer les les personnes
qui n'ont pas le droit d'asile
on serait d'accord très vite mais c'est
pas ça c'était qu' il y à des pays qui
qui ne semblent pas prêts du tout
accueillir des personnes en danger qui
qui qui sont vraiment dès qu'ils ont un
droit d'asile selon le droit européen et
et c'est ça c'est un manque de
solidarité complète et il faut il faut
essayer de d'avancer là de trouver des
solutions
la commission les seuils actuellement
avec un nouveau plan où il y a des des
mesures différentes que chaque pays peut
plus ou moins choisir comment contribuer
à la politique commune d'asile
l'immigration déjà par exemple et enfin
a dit que pour lui c'était pas du tout
satisfaisant alors katarina parler comme
votre nom lundi que vous êtes la fille
d'un père britannique ancien journaliste
à la 2e vélo et vous avez à la double
nationalité allemande britannique le hms
exit qui ne voit toujours pas la fin de
ce processus de négociations sur un
accord commercial est certainement un
procès à un processus très douloureux
pour vous en tout cas absolument
personnellement c'est vraiment c'était
une catastrophe le jour du référendum
heureusement ma famille britannique est
absolu absolument contre les brigitte
donc
nous ne vivons pas cette rupture de
liaison familial quand d'autres d'autres
familles au en grande bretagne alors
lisez le royaume uni et l'union
européenne cette semaine ont encore
intensifier leurs négociations mais il y
à beaucoup de tensions y compris parmi
les états membres
peut-être une division de l'europe qui
commence à s'opérer entre ceux qui sont
très intéressés par la pêche
et puis les autres et on reproche
peut-être même à l'allemagne de vouloir
un accord à tout prix alors ce qui est
vraiment important à dire c'est que le
tactique du royaume uni de séparer les
pays membres les autres pays membres
londres n'a pas fonctionné et je suis
très très fier on est resté ensemble et
on ne va pas se faire divisé maintenant
aux derniers mètres bien sûr je paie mon
bras des intérêts différents
mais mais jusqu'à présent et j'espère
que ça ça reste jusqu'à 3 en considère d
d d d intérêt compte des intérêts
européens
et c'est comme ça quand dirige les
négociations et je trouve que michel
barnier ne le fais vraiment très bien
si vous dites encore intensifier les
négociations les négociations pendant
des années n'étaient pas vraiment des
négociations on s'est rencontré et on
s'est dit les mêmes choses de chaque
fois et on se séparer de nouveau mais
c'est seulement il y a quelques semaines
qu'elle est que les politiciens
britanniques boris johnson vraiment gère
des négociations sérieuses et maintenant
bien sûr le temps c'est pas assez pour
avoir un vrai accord à mon accord si en
si on a un accord à la fin ce sera
quelque chose de très léger qui ne
comprend pas toutes les matières c'est
complètement impossible alors le
gouvernement britannique l'a par
ailleurs annoncé
avoir accordé son feu vert au vaccin
après recommandation de son agence
indépendante de réglementation des
médicaments et dit-il grâce au breakbeat
il va pouvoir procéder encore plus vite
pourquoi pourquoi plus vite d'ailleurs
que les 27 autres à c'est une bonne
question
d'abord je suis très fier que ce vaccin
était développé juste 100 km de chez moi
à mayence ont envahi lundi palatinat où
j'habite et aussi subventionné par des
moyens européens donc c'est aussi je
trouve un succès européen et les
l'administration dans tous les pays
membres
c'est son mieux je suis très sûr de cela
mais il faut le faire vraiment bien
donc je ne sais pas pourquoi les
britanniques sont 100 plus vite que les
autres
peut-être il y a beaucoup de pression
aussi
politiques parce que vous savez que la
situation de co vide au royaume uni est
extrêmement intense extrêmement grave
donc je ne sais pas j'espère je suis
convaincu qu'ils aient qu'ils sont le
mieux aussi et que c'est un processus
correct aussi nous alors juste dernière
question sur cette présidence allemande
qui se termine en disait au 31 décembre
présidence tournante
qu'est ce qui en ferait une présidence
réussie selon vous elle doit réussir
quoi exactement
pour qu'on dise à bac l mél présidence
c'était vraiment une présidence
difficile à il faut le dire parce que
déjà les acceptations était énorme et
parce qu'il y avait le budget il y avait
le break 6 et en plus et avait donc le
la crise qu vide alors si on gère ces
trois sets ses trois meilleurs plus
grands matière
bien et le budget au moins c'était je
crois que c'est un grand succès d'avoir
un budget qui est vraiment aide aux pays
qui sont le plus touchés par pablo
qu'ovide je crois que ça c'est
l'héritage le plus important merci à mon
invité d'avoir été en notre compagnie
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis vous
restez avec nous bien sûr on reparle de
la question du breakbeat l'impossible
accord c'est tout de suite le débat avec
trois eurodéputés ma camarade de public
sénat marie brimo a tout de suite
merci de nous rejoindre pour la seconde
partie d'ici l'europe encore une semaine
de négociation haletantes autour d'un
accord commercial sur le breakbeat dans
leur dernière ligne droite ses
négociations alors que la patience des
27 est mise à rude épreuve car la fin de
la période de transition est toujours
fixée au 31 décembre de cette année
voilà pourquoi il faut trouver un accord
sur la future relation commerciale post
break site avec trois sujets qui ont
vampirisé les discussions
l'accès aux zones de pêche les règles
d'une concurrence équitable et puis le
mécanisme de règlement des litiges
les européens sont ils prêts à toutes
sortes de concessions pour obtenir un
deal et peuvent-ils se divisaient sur
son opportunité alors à quel jeu joue
boris johnson en pleine pandémie qui
frappe durement les économies et alors
que la course contre la montre est en
train de s'achever
nous poserons évidemment la question à
nos trois invités du jour tous
eurodéputés ou anciens nour député c'est
votre cas depuis aberdeen en écosse qui
ce christian allard ancien noro députés
écossais des verts membre du parti
national écossais qui est
indépendantiste qui voudrait donc
l'indépendance de l'ecosse bonjour à
vous est avec nous depuis bruxelles
depuis le parlement européen pascal
durand eurodéputés également vous
appartenez à renault europe
votre pays la france est
particulièrement impacté 1 par la
perspective du bric site pour ses
exportations et son secteur pêche alors
à bruxelles toujours antonio lopes
history ce white bonjour vous êtes
député européen espagnol du parti
populaire européen l'espagne semble a
priori moins impactés par les
négociations en cours mais elle est
inquiète par rapport par exemple l
enclave britannique de gibraltar ou
encore aux retraités britanniques sur
votre sol on en parlera
pascal durand pourquoi on en est encore
à piétiner à trois semaines de la date
limite de la date butoir
et bien parce que pour une grande part
boris johnson et ses alliés ont menti à
la population anglaise en expliquant que
le break site allait permettre à la
grande bretagne de reprendre sa
souveraineté de que tout allait être
simple que tout allait être réglé comme
par enchantement la réalité et on le
sait depuis très longtemps c'est que
c'est extrêmement compliqué d'arriver il
y a des il ya énormément des changes à
la fois commerciaux mais humain il ya
des petits à trois millions de citoyens
européens et britanniques qui sont d'une
part sur le continent où d'autre part au
sein de l'île et donc on voit très bien
que ces imbrications font qu' on est
dans une quasi impasse pour trouver des
solutions qui ne soient pas finalement
la reproduction de ce qu'il y avait
avant
c'est à dire en gros une liberté des
changes est aussi bien sur les citoyens
que sur les biens et services est donc
le problème il est là et par ailleurs je
pense que boris johnson joue la montre
parce qu'il se dit les européens
finalement vont se diviser à la fin et
attendre le dernier moment et dans la
dernière nuit je trouverai un bon accord
il a tort
les 27 sont extrêmement unie alors de
l'autre côté de la manche christian
allard comment on perçoit cette tactique
de boris johnson
supposée en tout cas on a beaucoup parlé
d'un sur place pendant des semaines dans
les négociations il semble que le
premier ministre britannique a repris un
peu la main mais pour aller où et à quel
rythme le premier ministre britannique
boris johnson a été appelé le petit
frère de donald trompe est pas pour rien
c'est quelqu'un qui a promis beaucoup
pour devenir premier ministre promet
beaucoup pendant la campagne du
président
et bien sûr
le brésil ne s'est pas passé aussi
facilement qu'il aurait dû puisqu'il
l'avait dit que en deux ans ça serait
tout bouclé et que nous aurions les
mêmes droits et merci monsieur pascal
durand de de rappeler que c'est bien sûr
les personnes c'est le plus important
dans d'endosser dans ces accords et je
suis français qui vit ici en
grande-bretagne en écosse à l'aller 3
millions et morrison nous avait promis
que nous gagnerons les mêmes droits
après le président il est avéré que bien
sûr ce n'est pas vrai boris johnson
voulait premier ministre il est comme
donald rond boulet président il l'a été
le reste m'importe peu il a démontré
déjà avec des landes du nord où il a
promis monts et merveilles et après à
cet effet des landes yeux lors il le
fera la même chose pour les gosses il y
fera la même chose pour les sociétés
britanniques toutes les entreprises
britanniques qui dépendent énormément du
marché européen
donc nos cheminées l'opposition tels
difficile on l'entend antonio lopez
isturiz white seuls huit pays sont
concernés ain fall par la pêche dans les
eaux britanniques dont la france
l'irlande la belgique les pays-bas la
suède l'allemagne et le danemark
et votre pays en espagne est-ce que les
dix neuf autres sont tentés de lâcher du
lest sur ce chapitre sur lequel un boris
johnson restent intraitables et de se
désolidariser pour obtenir un accord pas
du tout c'est pas une question de huit
pays
c'est une question de 27 pays et sa
queue russie à michel barnier comme chef
négociateur pendant ces trois années de
négociations
c'était la clé de notre unité royaume
uni a toujours tenté un de faire cette
division continentale ça c'est la
première fois que sa part marché en
espagne et nous que nous sommes dans la
position l'espagne ont fait toujours
confiance dans les capacités et l'unité
et les qualités qu'ils pressentent miss
alba rien sur ces négociations nous
restons toujours attentif le l'annoncé
d'un possible blocage qui considèrent
c'est toujours ce type de déclarations
c'est normal est en avant de quelques
conseils européens
il ya ces grandes déclarations on verra
mais aussi sur l'espagne comme pays
intéressés suivra avec beaucoup
d'intérêt cette position c'est français
j'espère comme le beige et le suédois
le reste des pays je suis sûr suivre on
sait ce qui se passe avec séduit pays
comme on fait comme on fait toujours
avec l'irlande tout l'europe à rester
unie avec l'irlande sur le score de
vendredi sans donc je pense que cette
unité et les qualités c'est sont
essentielles dans ces négociations
alors d'ailleurs pascal durand emmanuel
macron président français a dû taper du
poing sur la table sur le mandat de
michel barnier il ne veut pas d'un
accord trop conciliant kit aboutir à un
odile il est rejoint dans cette
rhétorique par quelques pays seulement
les pays bas la belgique l'espagne le
danemark il parle maintenant aussi d'un
veto à un mauvais accord
pourquoi et surtout est-ce que la france
n'est pas un peu isolé dans cette
fermeté non ça vient d'être dit par par
mon collègue antonio lopez les les
vingt-sept sont extrêmement unie
moi je rends hommage évidemment à michel
barnier et pourtant nous ne sommes pas
du même groupe politique mais michel
barnier fait un travail absolument
remarquable pour essayer de maintenir
cette cette unité on sait que le
l'europe s'est unie dans la diversité
est bien là nous avons mis l'accent sur
l'unité
en fait ce que dit emmanuel macron sait
simplement qu'il explique à boris
johnson on est dans des négociations et
on est donc à un moment aussi dans des
rapports de force parce que ça a été le
souhait de monsieur johnson ça a été le
chou et aussi d'une partie des blocs
sitter britannique de jouer le rapport
de force et de et de gonfler
les pectoraux et de dire mais nous nous
déciderons de tous et est ce que dit
emmanuel macron ces noms vous n'aurez
pas il le dit au nom des 27 et je n'ai
aucun doute sur le fait que tout le
monde soit sur la même ligne et le
parlement sera sur cette ligne nous en
avons déjà débattu entre nous nous ne
validerons pas n'importe quel accord
nous n'accepterons pas un accord qui
porte atteinte aux droits des citoyens
qui portent atteinte au droit de la
concurrence sont surtout qui mettrait en
péril l'économie aussi des 27 pays donc
il faut être très clair et je soutiens
évidemment le président macron était et
tous ceux qui se sont exprimés d'autres
s'expriment wassa presser les questions
de caractère jeune je ne fais pas de
commentaires sur le fait que d'autre
part le peut-être moins mais clairement
nous savons que nous voulons un accord
global
un accord sur les quatre libertés et si
nous n'avons pas cet accord alors
effectivement nous ne validerons pas
après soyons clairs le no deal est un
perdant perdant pour tout le monde c'est
très clair christian allard justement
faute de temps car tout doit être
ratifié un par le parlement européen et
britannique est ce qu'on ne va pas
aboutir un accord cadre a minima quitte
à régler les points d'achoppement
après le 31 décembre 2009 c'est fort
possible que nous serons luigi de 2,2
d'avoir une prolongation encore après
fait cette période de transition
le droit des citoyens pas par exemple
c'est quelqu'un de très important et
j'ai donc au dernier discours au
parlement européen
j'ai commandé monsieur michel barnier
pour son sang-froid
donc je vous demande tous à garder votre
sang froid je pense que le président
macron a tout à fait raison de rester
très ferme pour le droit des citoyens
les citoyens en irlande du nord est les
citoyens européens en ayant en irlande
du nord et européens ici en écosse où je
vous le rappelle ont voté pour rester
dans l'union européenne
les gosses à voter à 62% pour rester
dans l'union européenne donc nous sommes
des nations qui se sent très européenne
nous connaissons nos droits et nous
voulons nous voulons les conserver
donc s'il vous plaît pensez à nous
penser à l'élan du nord gardez votre
sang froid rester ferme et penser que
les causes peut revenir très rapidement
au sein de l'union européenne comme une
écosse indépendante et eicher a
peut-être la première nation de la
grande bretagne qui reviennent dans
l'union européenne
et ça fait à l'avenir il faut commencer
à construire aujourd'hui monsieur is to
his white alors sur les dossiers de
concurrence déloyale du royaume uni qui
fait peur un véritablement aux
vingt-sept et de règlement des
différends entre ses 27 et le
royaume-uni encore qu'est ce qui bloque
principalement et pourquoi c'est si
important premier tout soyons honnêtes
l'adoption de la loi sur marché
intérieur par la grande bretagne
ils ne sont pas beaucoup on ne trouvera
pas beaucoup de familles dans le
parlement européen sur ce sujet là je
viens juste une petite sauce ce qui me
collait qu'on dise où la question à
michel barnier
je vois rappeler tout le monde qui est
aussi avec michel barnier c'est la
première fois que la transparence dans
des négociations européennes c'était la
clé aussi expliqué michel barnier nous
ça offrit au parlement européen je ne
peux pas rappeler combien de fois me
chevallier à venir au parlement a donné
témoignages tu te laisses aspects de
cette négociation
c'est pour ça que je sais confiance et
comme espagnol et comme députée
européenne sur son incapacité absolument
démontrer mais est pour pour son travail
et les soutiens à tous les pays
européens dans son univers intérêt sur
la question de la concurrence une fois
de plus c'était toujours le premier
choses dans notre stratégie au parti
populaire européen à notre premier
sommet 2016 après terrible nouvelle de
corexit c'était toujours de poser la
question de la qualité et qualité entre
une différence entre le royaume uni et
l'union européenne
on ne veut pas on ne veut pas d'une
marché unique à la carte
et c'était toujours dans le discours de
michel barnier je suis sûr aussi mes
collègues sont absolument d'accord avec
sa sève le groupe politique n'a terni
sur ça pascal durand la fédération
nationale des transports routiers du pas
de calais a dénoncé cette semaine là il
ya quelques jours une gestion
calamiteuse des flux de poids lourds en
direction du royaume uni dont la forte
augmentation génère des embouteillages
les britanniques constituent des stocks
de marchandises avant que le brick city
ne devienne effectif ça nous donne déjà
un aperçu des dégâts d'un odile
absolument mais c'est un ccd dégâts
d'ailleurs qui vont peser lourd y
compris aux britanniques par exemple sur
la pêche
parce qu on est en train de nous
expliquer que seuls les pêcheurs
français serait victime d'un odile et
bien entendu il faut les entendre dans
l'eure dans leur situation qui va être
une situation de crise
mais boris johnson mots là aussi au
britannique en faisant croire aux
pêcheurs aux britanniques ils vont
pouvoir s'en sortir sans un deal parce
que est ce que vous venez de dire pour
les camions vaut pour les poissons frais
cercle à la criée l'essentiel des
poissons qui sont pêchés y compris par
les pêcheurs britanniques viennent sur
le continent et sont vendus frais à la
criée de boulogne donc si les camions ne
peuvent plus circuler
si nous sommes dans des situations
d'embouteillage et bien les poissons
britannique
même avec un beau drapeau et l'hymne
yanchak dessus ne pourrons pas arriver
frais et ne pourront pas être vendu à la
criée de boulogne ne pourront pas aller
sur le continent non plus donc c'est une
perte de marché considérable c'est pour
ça que je disais que
odile et cette situation ce rapport de
force voulue par boris johnson et par
ses conseillers est une situation qui
est extrêmement dommageable mais
dommageable à l'ensemble des partis vers
la seule bonne nouvelle est vraiment
c'est que et ça a été dit et je confirme
ce qu'on me dit mais des mes deux
collègues c'est que ça renforcer la
détermination et l'unité de l'union
européenne à agir et à parler d'une
seule voix ça a fait grandir la
démocratie européenne
et ça permet à mes amis écossais
notamment d'essayer de faire entendre
leur voix et je l'espère bientôt pouvoir
nous rejoindre au sein de l'union prise
donc ça ce sont les bonnes nouvelles
mais les mauvaises nouvelles
effectivement c'est qu'on va vers des
difficultés économiques majeures pour
les uns et pour les autres tout dernier
tour de table il nous reste quelques
secondes pour conclure effectivement
christian allard et monsieur x touriste
white quelles conséquences d'un odile
elles sont toujours très négative on
écoute outre-manche d'abord monsieur
allard mais sur un plan très négatives
elles sont gravées pour la pêche
bien sûr puisque la pêche elle est
principalement et ikotel 60 du pot sans
de l'appel britannique étant les coques
et comme monsieur pascal durand la vie
il a tout à fait raison
pour nous c'était une réunion dans le
nord-est dans l'école il y a quelques
semaines où la recherche est très très
est très précise très vite elle risque
principal pour la pêche écossaise ici en
négociant un break qui sont sans accord
sera tout à fait une qualité pour nos
entreprises
les côtés pour nous - pêcheurs pour nous
ma meilleure et pour nous et pour tout
dire l'espagne et du côté européen
selon monsieur se hisse tourisme ait je
veux parler des catastrophes déjà
aujourd'hui et un accord est toujours
préférable 1900 d'accord déjà notre
économie souffre pour la question déco
vite on doit traiter est très très
intelligent un pâle approche à je
respecte beaucoup les déclarations de
grandes déclarations avant du 10 au 31
décembre
mais on doit laisser maintenant le clip
qui négocie sa tranquillité et cinq fois
ce qui a été reconnu par des collègues
sous la question de la nomination de
michel barnier mais aussi je vais
ajouter une sauce je suis sûr que dans
l'éventualité d'une absence
nous sommes prêts je peux pas dire la
même chose du royaume uni et de
gouvernement on verra ça et ce seront
les mots de la fin merci à tous les
trois pour ce débat qui devrait trouver
sa conclusion sous peu est à suivre sur
nos deux antennes à très bientôt à tous
[Musique]